[Music]
we're doing it not too scary we're gonna
die don't die we're doing it some might
say that I'm lost I think you're lost
well we're kind of lost but I kind of
know where we are but it's part of the
adventure it's part of the adventure
[Music]
good morning
time for our last day in Paris I needed
to do so well last night
and today is just gonna be an
integration day so we're gonna
we're gonna think about the business
we're gonna think about our lives we're
going to maybe go down the scooter and
take you on a journey with us we'll see
what happens great things happen
foreign
decided to do a scooter yeah around the
city today
he's trying to figure out how to use the
scooter he has to look at the menu so we
have the pause the instructions okay
that's a good sign did you turn it on
yep okay I'll let you ride outside for a
couple of minutes first you sure no no
to make sure it's safe before I can go
down I don't want to die
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
I think we probably just Row one
kilometer Evan what do you think it's
great yeah I was I was I was scared
uh standing in front of him my legs are
actually a little tight and jiggly
where we going
we're gonna go to a Starbucks by the
Luda but I'm not quite sure how to get
there
we go
[Music]
foreign
is hunting for the best Starbucks
and then Paris but I don't know he's
gonna find it some might say that I'm
lost I think you're lost well we're kind
of lost but I kind of know where we are
but it's part of the adventure it's part
of the adventure you'll like it we'll
like it when we get there and we get to
we get to it's part of the adventure
let's go it's the best
foreign
[Music]
found the Starbucks it looks very
different fancy is Starbucks in Paris
we're gonna do planning session it's a
deep dive planning session life business
expansion so we need a grand place to
make a grand plan
's got the paper got the coffee we're
ready all right
I haven't had a good session hey we did
great yeah high five okay great Nina was
amazing
really I feel like I didn't do anything
you did great you came up with most of
the ideas I facilitated you've created
the environment and the space for magic
to happen I'm so excited we're not done
but round one is done uh Nina went to
the Washington was gross she told me I
can't go there so because it's really
gross so I'm gonna we're gonna go home
I'm to figure out how to get home
and uh we'll continue with our day and
get ready for brainstorming session Park
yeah
we're doing man not too scary don't die
don't die we're doing it
okay we got back safely we didn't die
that was great even Nina did a little
b-roll while we're on the studio yeah it
was like kind of dangerous my whole arm
instead yeah this whole arm sword yeah
it's super sore looks like you had a
good workout today it did arm workout
yeah and calves workout yeah yeah the
legs
that didn't want Nina to hurt to get
hurt you know so you gotta protected
hands tighten up
we went back to the hotel we did some
work and then decided to come back to
come out to go for a walk and I have a
huge headache and I picked this
restaurant has a lot of flowers
so this restaurant is called the flame
it means fire the foil needs the flame
okay yeah but it has a lot of flower
decoration so I thought it was flour
you're the flower am I the flower pretty
one yeah
[Music]
I got onion soup
I haven't got a pizza
good reviews yeah Pizza is a French
thing apparently yeah
good reviews good huh
yeah surprisingly good okay good then
so we didn't do anything today well it's
apart from the scooter we went for lunch
and then we just came back and chilled
because I have a big headache from last
night I think I have too much to drink
last night and have big head enough and
right now we're going to Italian
restaurant because I've been feeling
like I want some hot food I feel like
most of the French food they're cold so
I need some hot food and we're here at
Italian restaurant in France
[Music]
smells really good
was it good very rich yeah very hot
not too hot
good choice yeah
dinner was really good price sir yeah
all right yes surprisingly better than
most of the restaurant that we have gone
right
might be the best yeah yeah I think so I
mean the cruise the cruise that was
really good yeah so we're gonna go home
no go back to the hotel pack up and
leave tomorrow exciting taking you with
us all right it is the next day day that
we go home we have packed everything up
I packed most of them I had to give
myself credit now we're gonna
get home hop on over and get home
get home here okay
so we have arrived at the airport it was
um calm and relaxing and I fell asleep I
have evidence and Camera are you filming
me yeah yeah okay now yeah I don't know
you close your eyes yeah
okay we're gonna find our gating
let's go yeah go home
yeah so we finally boarded we I went
around to the airport get some duty-free
snacks and dessert or whatever is from
Paris I got something for the kid and
for us and for my one of the manager
that I used to work with
his birthday
is next week so I got him something
he liked French food so let's go
yeah time to pour
[Music]
so we landed at least
um half an hour already uh Evan's not
feeling so well
but we're gonna get home soon and see
the doggies
Timo we're home
oh my goodness oh my goodness
[Music]
thank you
so we are now home I hope you enjoyed
the trip and the journey and if you want
to see why we went to Paris on day one
and what that Journey looked like from
the start there's a video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you